there's no Peter Parker or Miles Morales
in the trailer for Madame Webb but
plenty of other spider people appear who
are they and how close are their
costumes to their Comics counterparts
fans of Sony Spider-Man universe have
had to do some waiting this year as the
release date for Craven the hunter was
pushed back from October 2023 to August
2024 but they at least got the trailer
for Madame Webb yet another adaptation
of a classic Spider-Man character from
the studio the 2024 feature will start
toota Johnson as a clairvoyant Title
Character it seems as though she'll find
herself protecting a new generation of
spider heroes in three young women Julia
Carpenter played by Sydney Sweeney
mattity Franklin played by celesto
Connor and Anya corazone played by
Isabella mased I can see the
future oh what the hell she didn't see
that coming that's not how it works
perhaps due to their connection to one
another and The Wider web of spider
people these soon Tobe spider women must
survive being hunted by Ezekiel Sims a
deadly operator with as of yet are no
motivations play by tah Rahim Ezekiel
Sims is the odd spider out in the
trailer and that's not just because he's
trying to kill everyone else the
character wears a chilling black and red
suit that is a far cry from the
character's Comics attire in the comics
Sims has powers almost identical to
those of Peter Parker but received them
long before as part of an ancient ritual
instead of becoming a superhero he
became an immensely powerful businessman
who would use his powers sparingly so
the comics version of Ezekiel doesn't
really have a costume in the traditional
sense in one alternate universe Sim
steals a costume from a variant of
Spider-Man that was killed by Moran one
of the inheritors who is basically an
energy vampire ezekiel's typical Comics
apparel doesn't appear to have
influenced his Madam web look probably
at least in part due to a casually
dressed villain cutting in on action
figure sales you Foria star Sydney
Sweeney will make her superhero debut
with Madame Webb playing the seemingly
bookish Julia Carpenter in the comics
she has adopted the Monica's Spiderwoman
Arachne and even Madame Webb all after
someone else had those names it appears
as though Sweeney will be sporting the
original black and white bodysuit
Carpenter War when she first debuted in
the first secret War Series in 1984 the
design of this costume especially at
sprawling white Insignia will likely
remind fans of another character Venom
unlike Peter Parker's symbiote suit that
became Venom there's nothing alien about
Carpenter's outfit carp winter suit
actually debuted the issue before Parker
did and it stated that the now iconic
white symbiote spider symbol was
subconsciously inspired by her design it
would be a clever twist if Sony adapted
the story beat and allow Tom Hardy's
Eddie Brock to finally adopt the emblem
after seeing sween's Carpenter in action
why would I do that Anya corazone was
first introduced in a 2004 issue of
Amazing Fantasy as the superhero Arana
she has two main Comics costume Styles
one of which includes the large bugy
goggles SE for a brief moment in the
trailer her first costume is a
relatively casual tactical outfit that
consists of a vest tank top and jeans
all of which fit a red black and yellow
color Motif after meeting Julia
Carpenter corazone is given a black
bodysuit with white accents very similar
to her new friends under the new Alias
spider girl corazone wears his black and
white suit through several minor
alterations until it is destroyed by the
super villain Vermin at which point she
returns to something closer to her
original look based on a very brief look
at corazon's costume in the Madame web
trailer it appears as though she'll be
wearing something closer to her second
costume but with goggles from the first
unlike her friend's Black costumes Matty
Franklin wears the traditional blue and
red colors of Peter Parker Spider-Man
that maybe a nod to her uniquely close
Comics connection to the original web
Slinger after getting superpowers and
the mystical Gathering a five ceremony
organized by Norman Osborne Matty
briefly took over for petza as
Spider-Man while he was temporarily
retired after after Peter put the webs
back on she became the third Spiderwoman
her infatuation with Peter created some
bizarre friction between them though we
don't expect that to play into her role
in Madame Webb that's because lots of
signs point to Madame Webb being a
prequel of sorts a popular Theory online
speculates and his IMDb credits indicate
that Adam Scott's suspiciously named
character is actually a young Ben Parker
Peter's Uncle who dies in most versions
of his origin story that Meme Madame
Webb takes place well before any other
Spider-Man story and Franklin couldn't
have any connection to the most famous
War crawler around fans will have to
wait to see when Madame Webb debuts on
February 14th